[Music]
the agenda
it is so decided
hello
mr president
the united nations remains gravely
concerned about the dangerous situation
in and around the zappariya nuclear
power plant in southern ukraine the
plant continues to be operated by
ukrainian technical personnel
but has been under the control of the
military forces of the russian
federation since early march
in early august disturbing reports of an
escalation of shelling around the plant
began to emerge
the secretary general has appealed to
all concerned to exercise common sense
and reason and to refrain from
undertaking any actions that might
endanger the physical integrity safety
or security of the nuclear plant
europe's largest
on 15 august the secretary general
discussed the issue of the plant's
safety during the call with russian
minister of defense sergey shoigu
on 18 august during his visit to levive
he discussed the situation with
ukrainian president volodymir
in all his statements and meetings
the secretary general has continued to
call for all military activities in the
immediate vicinity of the plant to cease
immediately and for all sides to refrain
from targeting its facilities or
surroundings
all military personnel and equipment
must be withdrawn from the plant there
should be no further deployment of
forces or equipment to the site
the facility must not be used as part of
any military operation and an agreement
on a safe parameter of demilitarization
to ensure the safety of the area should
be reached
regrettably despite numerous calls and
appeals instead of de-escalation we
continue to see the almost daily reports
of alarming incidents involving the
plant
today the director general of the iaea
renewed his request to send an iaea
mission to carry out essential safety
security and safeguard activities at the
site
preparations for the mission are
proceeding and the iaea is in active
consultations with all parties regarding
its efforts to send such a mission as
soon as possible
we welcome ukraine and russia's recent
statements
indicating support for the iaea's aim to
send a mission to the plant which would
be iaea's first to that site since the
start of the war
mr president common sense must prevail
to avoid any actions that might endanger
the physical integrity safety or
security of the plant
as the secretary general stressed in his
briefing at the council
yesterday the commitment to dialogue and
results must be applied to the critical
situation at the plant
if such incidents continued to escalate
we could face a disaster
the united nations continues to fully
support the critical work of the
international atomic energy agency and
its efforts to ensure the safe operation
of the zaparica nuclear power plant and
other nuclear facilities in ukraine
in close contact with the iaea
the un has assessed that we have the
logistics and security capacity in
ukraine to support any iaea mission to
the plant from kiev provided
ukraine and russia agree
we once again urge the parties to
provide the iaea mission with immediate
secure and unfettered access to the site
agreement is urgently needed to
re-establish zaparisia as purely
civilian infrastructure and to ensure
the safety of the area
we must be clear
that any potential damage to the plant
or any other nuclear facilities in
ukraine
leading to a possible nuclear incident
would have catastrophic consequences not
only for the immediate vicinity but for
the region and beyond
similarly
any damage leading to the plant being
cut from the ukrainian power grid would
have catastrophic humanitarian
implications
particularly with winter approaching
as the secretary general has made clear
the electricity produced at the
zaparisia plant belongs to ukraine
at this moment it is imperative that we
receive the express commitment of the
parties to stop any military activities
around the plant and to enable its
continued safe and secure operations
to paraphrase the secretary general's
blend warning
any potential damage to zapposia is
suicidal thank you mr president
okay
to the members of the security council
like you before to the representative of
the russian federation
we heard her words when she said that
the electricity of this aboriginal mpp
belongs with to ukraine but i would like
to
draw your attention to the fact that
with the knives didn't hear similar
words from the secretariat about the
frozen russian financial
assets that are frozen in the west or
the syrian oil
that are being held by the american
authorities we're illegally occupying
syria we've never heard that
since the last meeting of the security
council on this apparition npp um about
two weeks have passed and in the course
of that time the nuclear safety
situation has further deteriorated
the armed forces of ukraine continue
basically every day to shell the
territory of the npp and the town of
inergador and this creates a real risk
of a radiation accident
and these apparatus npp with
catastrophic consequences for the entire
european continent
according to the information that the
ministry of defense of russia has and
the administration of this apparatus
obelisk on the 11th of august the 44th
artillery brigade of the
ukrainian armed force shelled the
station using 152 millimeter shells as a
result of that
the
equipment of spray ponds within the
nuclear reactors cooling system was
damaged
on the 14th
of august the armed forces of ukraine
had 10 shellings of the npp using 150
millimeters shells for m-77 house houses
which are american-made and two guided
munitions were launched as a result of
that one person died in an ago an ergod
one further person was wanted on the
15th of august
30 shells were launched for 152
millimeter artillery uh facilities on
the 17th 11 shells and also kamikaze
unmanned aerial vehicle was launched
which is polish made
three strikes were made by loitering
munitions on an air guitar
on the 18th of august
there were seven shellings you using
heavy artillery on the 20th of act
august from the ukrainian forces
positions once again there was shelling
against the npp using heavy artillery
and american-made shells for 155
militar caliber caliber using
m3379 artillery fuse which is
american-made there was an ulterior
strike against the specialized ancillary
buildings one and two and the lab and
amenities buildings
as a result
the lab amenities buildings number two
was damaged the hydraulics unit building
was damaged and lighting of the station
was damaged immediately after the
shelling fire was opened against the
suburbs over near qatar
on the 22nd of august and uav
struck the lab in amenities building
number two furthermore the american long
artillery was used to shell the thermal
power station in india
according to our information one
civilian died and one was wounded
i just wanted to show you now a photo of
the destruction on the territory of this
operation nuclear power plant as a
result of shellings by the ukrainian
armed forces
we have a whole slew of such
photographic evidence and we
disseminated it this morning as an
official document within the security
council and the g.a
the fact that the kiev regime continues
with attacks on the station is a direct
consequence of criminal acquiescence on
the part of its western patrons
at the last meeting not a single western
delegation had the courage to con to
condemn the shelling of the station by
the ukrainian armed forces in asking
cave and regime to stop it
nor was the courage found in european
capitals the capitals are simply
launching an appeals to russia to stop
the so-called recent activities
surrounding these aboriginal mpp we're
under an impression that our colleagues
exist in their own parallel reality in
which the russian military are
themselves shelling the station that
they are protecting and are using the
american systems for that
the pinnacle of this absurd was a recent
statement made by the uk
mp tobias elwood and member of the house
of representatives of the united states
adam kessinger when they said that the
shellings of the npp could be the reason
for invoking article 5 of nato at the
same time the western mass
media are using the conclusions of the
us arms control disarmament agency which
says that there is nothing dangerous for
the people in western europe in the
shelling of the npp or even in a
possible accident there well there will
be no
major disaster the station should
withstand the rocket strike and even if
it doesn't then the tongue of
radioactive contamination will not
reach western europe the fact that even
in this scenario at the very least the
people in this upper orsk are blessed
will suffer well our western colleagues
i think traditionally uh chalk off to
collateral damage
probably this is how they express their
concern about people and the
human uh centered security that we heard
so much about during yesterday's meeting
of the council
this is a cynical attitude towards the
people of ukraine
one other evidence of the fact that the
western handlers of kiev are not at all
worried about that and they stand ready
to fight until the very last ukrainian
the disaster as a result of the shelling
of the npp
so far we have been able to avoid only
because there's smooth joint work
between the workers of the station fire
squads emergency people and the russian
military who are helping them every way
they can
and this shows that there is a healthy
working atmosphere at this station and
no one is oppressing anyone there
despite the false statements made by the
kiev regime and its handlers russia is
not locating heavy weaponry at the
zaparoja npp and is not using the
station for military purpose the
military of defense stand ready to
provide iaea with high resolution photos
which shows the weaponry um all the less
so heavy weaponry is not located on the
territory of the station mr president
recently ukraine had the visit of the
u.n secretary general antonio guterres
and we pinned uh certain hopes on his
trip we expected the u.n finally will
demand that kiev stop shelling the
station
but
we didn't hear from the secretary words
of condemnation of what's going on other
than appeals to
um i quote that you military activity
should avoid the zamparoji npp i would
like to ask mr carlo whether the
secretary managed to obtain from
vladimir lenski promised to stop showing
the station what is the assessment of
the secretariat of the u.n that the
shelling of the station by ukraine
continue
in the light of the fact that iaa is
seriously concerned by the situation
from day one we have supported ia
efforts and it's direct director general
ravel grossi to organize a mission to
this apparatus npp and we did everything
we could to make sure that the experts
visit the agency visit
took place already in june
and we agreed to the mission already by
the third of june
at the time of the
trip did not happen through no fault of
our own today we hear absurd statements
in foreign uh mass media
that the foreign countries basically
pushed
russia to agree to the mission we expect
that the
iaea trip mission will take place in the
very near future and the agency experts
will confirm the real situation at the
station we stand ready to um
extend maximal support possible to
resolve organs all organizational issues
uh mr president i would like to now in
conclusion draw attention of the members
of the council to the tragedy in moscow
on the 20th of august
an explosion
of a car took place uh inside um the car
was a military police correspondent and
politologist daria ludogina
our competent authorities are
investigating this and preliminary
conclusions are that this monstrous
crime was organized by the ukrainian
special services
um it was determined who the uh uh
president doing that was and she is
connected to the azo battalion she
managed to escape to estonia
dario duguna was 29. her life was
stopped at its very height because of
his professional activity she
has been for a long
time followed by ukrainian nationalists
this is her photo on the emiratored site
the infamous one that we mentioned
several times and they are boasting
about her murder as you can see her
photo is crossed and the caption here is
eliminated
[Music]
was condemned by an official
representative of the us department of
state we called on the council and the
u.n leadership too condemned yet and
this yet another crime by the kiev
regime not only are they
using nuclear blackmail by shelling the
npp and
holding people in europe
postage but they also crossed all of the
lines and now physically eliminating
those civilians they do not
like and in this case we have a victim
who's an independent journalist she was
killed because of professional activity
the official representatives of the kiev
regime are openly calling for the murder
of russians the ukraine ambassador in
kazakhstan mr verblevsky stated publicly
recently that the goal of ukraine is to
kill as many russians as possible the
greater number of them are killed now
the fewer russians other generations of
the ukrainians would have to kill
we're outraged by the fact that the
western currency countries not only do
not condemn this but they help ukrainian
special services to prepare saboteurs to
eliminate the so-called undesirable ones
very good example the situation with the
ukrainian citizen mr karpenko who was
recruited by ukrainian services in
czechia and was being prepared to train
to mine and explode things in um a czech
city of cesky krumlov
he was taught how to lay explosive in
buildings and cars after that he was
sent to the donetsk people's republic to
conduct acts of terror in the admin
building of the
administration of the voldos region
fortunately carpenter turned himself in
but if he had done what he was trained
for the the scale of victims is is is
frightening to imagine in this context
we're not surprised that the authorities
of
czechia are openly uh expressing their
happiness that darya dugina died the
minister of defense of czechia
yanachanova stated that she has no pity
for daria or her father
and that i quote that the night of the
21st august in russia is something that
the russia will remember for a long time
and then subsequently confirmed that she
stands by every single word of hers
even if we set aside the morals um that
uh has been in our western colors
replaced by the russophobia
the this statement of mr chernova is an
open support and propaganda of acts of
terrorists against civilians i would
like to recall that mr chairman a czech
citizen who openly supported an act of
terror in christchurch was sentenced to
six years in czech air and we expect
that the carpenter authorities of
czechia will be equally serious about
the statement made by the ministry of
defense of this of their country and
will assess them accordingly i thank you
i thank the representative of the
russian federation for his statement and
then now give the floor to the
representative cabon
i thank you mr president
i thank under secretary general rosemary
dicarlo for her insightful briefing
in recent weeks
information on the risk
of a nuclear accident in ukraine
has become more insisting
the intensification of military activity
in the vicinity of the parisian nuclear
power plant and the allegation of the
use of this nuclear power plant
for military purposes
raised the specter
of a nuclear disaster with potential
incalculable consequences
a couple of weeks ago
we get rid in this room to express our
collective indignation
at the likelihood that such an outcome
could happen
all
military activity at nuclear sites must
cease
parties to the conflict must refrain
from any attacks including cyber attacks
on nuclear sites
and from any rhetoric that tends to use
nuclear risk
as a weapon of war
we call for independent and impartial
investigation to establish
responsibility for the attacks and other
bombings targeting
the zappos power plant
in the meantime
it is crucial that the belligerents
respect the nuclear security rules
enforce and cooperate with iaea
with a view to securing the sites
we welcome the intention expressed by
the parties to facilitate the conduct of
an iaea expert mission and we urge them
to find a common ground on the
operational modalities of this mission
which
we all call for ukraine as soon as
possible
it is not acceptable to wait and
speculate on the potential risk of
adding devastating environmental and
human health effects to the economic and
humanitarian impacts
after six months of war
suffering and destruction
we think it's time to bring back peace
to the hurt of our priority agenda
my country encourages all initiatives
aimed at bringing the parties to the
negotiating table for peaceful
coexistence
as long as the fighting continues
the situation in ukraine will surely
continue to worsen
the surest way to word of
multifaceted security trait is to end
hostilities
we encourage all political and
diplomatic efforts to stop escalation to
silence the guns
and reach an agreement for a lasting
peace between the parties
the grain agreement recently concluded
is a source of hope on the possibility
of convening a ceasefire agreement to
pave the way for good faith negotiation
for return to sustainable peace
my country supports all international
and regional efforts
aiming at restoring peace in ukraine i
thank you very much
i thank the representative gabon for his
statement
and now i give the floor to the
representative of the united arab
emirates
thank you mr president i'd like to thank
also miss dicarlo for her timely
briefing
since our last meeting on august 11th
the situation around the zaparoja
nuclear power plant continues to be
deeply alarming
despite urgent calls for de-escalation
we have continued to receive news of
shilling
in the proximity of the power plant
we underline once more that shilling
around nuclear facility puts ukraine the
wider region and the whole world at a
grave risk of a catastrophic nuclear
accident
the example of chernobyl has been
frequently invoked in this chamber and
elsewhere and with reason
we remember all too well the horrendous
consequences
the world cannot afford a scenario where
another such
calamity is even a possibility
when it comes to nuclear matters our
collective security is truly intertwined
it is a message that has been reinforced
these last weeks during the 10th review
conference of the parties of the mpt
here in new york
nuclear safety is a critical issue for
the united arab emirates and is a matter
of priority
we remain committed to supporting all
efforts ensuring the safety and security
of nuclear facilities globally including
through our work with the iaea and
through our participation at the iaea's
board of governors
in this regard we underline once again
that the importance of refraining
refraining from any action that could
further endanger the facility
particularly considering the volatile
and fraud situation
and we echo the iaea's director general
grossi's recent statement
calling for the urgent need to lower
tensions
near the plant
we further stress again that particular
protection accorded to nuclear plants
under international law
united arab emirates also reiterates the
importance of the iaea that the iaea has
full impeded access to the site in order
to assist the damage and assert the
safety of the facility
we welcome that both parties support
such a mission
and we urge that it can be conducted in
expeditious manner
mr president
we are a day away from making marking
six months since the beginning of the
conflict
it remains crucial to advocate for
constructive dialogue that would bring
the conflict to peaceful sustainable
resolution in a way that is consistent
with the u.n charter and international
law
the only way to truly stop the suffering
brought by this conflict and to stem its
consequences including the risk of a
catastrophic nuclear accident is through
achieving a cessation of hostilities
throughout ukraine
we the members of this council must work
towards fulfilling its mandate and take
incremental and programmatic steps to
support efforts toward diplomatic end to
the conflict i thank you mr president
i thank the representative of the uae
for his statement and now i give the
photo representative norway
thank you mr president and thank you usg
de carlo for your timely briefing
russia's ongoing war of aggression
against ukraine has endangered nuclear
safety and security in ukraine in the
russian federation in europe and beyond
and we reject the russian federation's
use of the security council as a
platform for disinformation
there is no doubt that the safety and
security in and around the separation
nuclear power plant has deteriorated
because of the presence of an armed
aggressor
russia's continued illegal war has
increased the risk of a nuclear accident
with potentially catastrophic
consequences for human health and the
environment
the director general of the
international atomic energy agency has
outlined seven indispensable pillars for
nuclear safety and security which we
fully endorse
we note with great distress that
virtually all seem to have been violated
as a consequence of russian aggression
we call for maximum military restraint
in the area of ukraine's super richer
nuclear power plant
and we emphasize the importance of
facilitating a mission from the iaea to
carry out essential safety security and
safeguards activities while fully
respecting ukrainian sovereignty
in this regard we note recent statements
indicated indicating that both ukraine
and russia could support the iaea aimed
to send a mission to saborita
mr president we remain concerned that
russia's seizure of a nuclear power
plant in ukraine is also a means of
taking hostage a central source of
electricity supply essential to the
civilian population of ukraine
we call on russia to return full control
of the plant to its ukrainian operator
and we commend ukraine for its
commitment and dedication to ensuring
continuous nuclear safety and security
under severe circumstances
mr president russia's illegal war and
unprovoked aggression has caused
terrible suffering for the people of
ukraine
and beyond including aggravating global
food insecurity
let me end by again reiterating that the
russian federation must immediately
withdraw its forces from ukraine and its
internationally recognized borders and
seize all threats and military actions
this would also restore ukraine's
ability to ensure safe and secure
operations of all of its nuclear
facilities i thank you mr president
i thank the representative of norway for
his statement and i would like to give
the four to the representative of the
united states thank you mr president
thank you for your briefing under
secretary general de carlo
we commend the secretary general for his
recent visit to ukraine
and we greatly appreciate the un's
continued efforts to address
the increasingly dangerous situation at
the zapariza nuclear power plant
colleagues
the issue at hand today is not some
abstract political debate
and this is not some far-off problem
as we speak
ukraine neighboring states the entire
international community
are living
under the threat of a nuclear
catastrophe
and people are understandably
terrified
people like tamara carlkova
a 70 year old grandmother who can see
the plant from her apartment building
she has nightmares about the plant
blowing up
as she told a reporter for national
public radio
all of us are just scared
all the time
and for what
why on earth is a nuclear facility being
used as a staging ground for war
by russian forces
these questions can only be answered by
president putin
and could have been answered by members
of the russian delegation
who sit here today
only they can explain why russia thinks
it can redraw international borders by
force
and contravention of the u.n charter
only they
can account for the atrocities they have
carried out against the ukrainian people
bombings of schools and hospitals
the killing of aid workers and
journalists execution-style murders
and the forced deportations of ukrainian
civilians
through so-called filtration operations
and only they can explain where their
troops
recklessly attacked and seized control
of this plant
pushing us to the brink of nuclear
disaster
i will recall again ukraine's impeccable
record of nuclear energy safety and
security prior to russia's seizure of
this facility
but we didn't hear answers from the
russian delegation what we heard were
references to a hodgepodge
of websites and tweets
and of course that's a double-edged
sword
as i would remind the russian delegation
it was the russian ambassador in vienna
who just a few days ago
tweeted no mercy
for the ukrainian people
nevertheless
a nuclear disaster at the plant is
avoidable
russia created this risk and only russia
can defuse it
the solution is not complicated
russia must end its unprovoked
unjustified war and withdraw its troops
and given the urgency of this situation
russia
must immediately
follow the recommendation of secretary
general guterres and establish a
demilitarized zone in the area
surrounding the plant
this would allow for the ukrainian
personnel
who are currently being held under
duress
to operate the facility complete a
damage assessment
and restore the facility's impeccable
safety security and safeguards
performance
and a demilitarized zone
would enable the iaea team
to travel to the facility
conduct an inspection and assess the
safety security and application of
safeguards to ongoing nuclear plant
operations
we also call on russia to agree to an
iaea visit to the facility
in a way that will respect ukrainian
sovereignty
and we echo the words of the
secretary-general
that the electricity from zapariza is
ukrainian electricity
and that this principle must be fully
respected
finally
let me close
by reminding my russian colleagues
that as we approach ukraine's
independence day
the world is watching
this should not need saying
but please do not bomb schools hospitals
orphanages or homes
we will continue to pursue
accountability for any and all
violations of international law
and today on the eve of the six-month
anniversary of russia's invasion
we reiterate the message that we have
shared with the russian delegation
throughout
their war of choice
in the suffering
in the bloodshed
in this war
thank you mr president
i thank the representative of the united
states for his statement now i give the
photo to the representative of ireland
thank you president and i'd like to
thank usgd carlow for your briefing
president ireland continues to be deeply
concerned by the situation at the
zaparia nuclear power plant and the
serious risk of a radiological accident
or incident arising from military
activity at that site
we are also very concerned by the
ongoing shelling at and around the power
plant which must stop immediately
the devastating consequences for the
people of ukraine and the wider region
of an accident or incident at zappo asia
should be the overriding concern for all
of us
we strongly support the secretary
general's call for the demilitarization
of the plant and its environs
president it is essential that basic
principles of nuclear safety and
security are fully respected
we call on russia and indeed all states
to commit themselves to the seven
pillars of nuclear safety and security
as set out by the iaea director general
regarding peaceful nuclear facilities
and materials in all circumstances
including in situations of armed
conflict
we commend the bravery and
professionalism of the ukrainian
personnel at the plant who have sought
to maintain its safe operation despite
being subjected to intolerable
circumstances by russian military forces
we strongly support an iaea mission to
the power plant to address safety
security and safeguards at the plant
respecting ukraine's sovereignty over
its full territory and infrastructure
we welcome secretary general guterres's
reaffirmation and as expressed by usg de
carlo that the un has the logistical and
security capacity to support the mission
from kiev to the nuclear power plant
it is vital that this mission can have
full access with no restrictions
we hope to see that mission take place
as soon as possible
we are also deeply worried by possible
efforts to disconnect the power plant
from the ukrainian electrical grid
in the circumstances this presents
significant dangers for nuclear safety
as well as for the humanitarian needs of
the people of ukraine who are relying on
it for their energy needs
president let's call a spade a spade
the issues at zappo asia arise solely
from russia's illegal war against
ukraine
the russian military have created this
crisis through their illegal seizure and
occupation of the zaparisha facility and
their reckless actions in ukraine which
have clearly demonstrated their utter
disregard for nuclear safety and
security
we recall that armed attacks against
nuclear facilities devoted to peaceful
purposes are violations of international
law including the principles of the un
charter
president as we have said before if
russia is genuine in its concern
regarding nuclear safety at zapposia it
must assume its responsibilities and end
its illegal occupation of the site
withdrawing its troops and munitions
this would see control of the plant
restored to the competent ukrainian
authorities supported by the iaea
ireland again calls on russia to end its
brutal war against the ukrainian people
and withdraw its troops from the entire
internationally recognized territory of
ukraine and to respect the sovereignty
and territorial integrity of its
neighbors thank you
okay i thank you representative ireland
for her statement now i give the photo
representative ghana thank you mr
president
at the outset i'd like to thank usg
rosemary dicarlo for the update on the
rising international safety concerns on
the state of the zaparisia nuclear power
plant in ukraine
when this council met on the same
subject a little over a week ago
the iaea through its director general
warned of potentially tragic
consequences for human lives and the
environment in the event of the
accidental leakage of radioactive
material from the nuclear facility
ghana regrets that despite the warnings
and spirited appeals from the
international community for all military
action around the facility to cease the
indiscriminate shelling attacks and
militarization of the nuclear facility
and its vicinity has continued
we are constrained to repeat once again
our grave alarm and condemnation of
these unacceptable developments
we wish to rema
sorry we wish to remind the armed
parties that the international law
including the 1977 amendment to the
geneva convention prohibits the conduct
of military conflicts around nuclear
sites we also call for the immediate and
full respect for the convention on the
fiscal protection of nuclear material
and its 2005 amendment by all the armed
parties we call for the demilitarization
of all the zones around ukraine's
nuclear facilities
in this repair respect ghana fully
supports an independent assessment of
the nuclear safety standards and
safeguards at the zaparizia facility to
assure that no breach has occurred for
this to happen however
it is crucial for the russian federation
which exercises control of the facility
to grant immediate access to the iaea in
order for the agency to conduct the
requisite assessment
we also stress the agency for the iaea
authorities to act quickly to assess the
danger and respond appropriately mr
president ghana continues to hold the
principal position
that there is no military solution to
the ongoing military hostilities we
therefore urge the intensification of
diplomacy and dialogue to
comprehensively address the underlying
security concerns and mistrust between
the warring parties furthermore while
the pursuit of diplomacy and dialogue is
prioritized we also strongly believe
that in parallel and unconditional
withdrawal of the invading troops of
russian federation from the
internationally recognized borders of
ukraine it's a conditioned precedent for
the restoration of the peace and
security of ukraine in conclusion we
reiterate our previous calls that the
plight of the civilians particularly
women and children and the growing
humanitarian threats should override all
other considerations as we seek to stop
this needless war i thank you
okay
i thank the representative of ghana for
her statement now i give the phone to
the representative of india president
let me begin by thanking under secretary
general rosemary de carlo for the update
focusing on the safety and security of
nuclear facilities in ukraine
we continue to carefully follow
developments regarding the safety and
security of ukraine's nuclear facilities
india attaches high importance to
ensuring the safety and security of
these facilities as any accident
involving nuclear facilities could
potentially have disastrous consequences
for public health and the environment
we also accord high priority to the
discharge by the iaea of its safeguards
and monitoring activities in accordance
with its statute in an effective
objective and efficient manner and we
value the efforts of the agency in this
regard
india remains concerned over the
situation at the zaparica nuclear power
plant we support the ongoing efforts
including that of the iaea
to reduce tensions and steps to ensure
nuclear safety and security at the
facility
we've noted the latest information
available with regard to nuclear power
plants and facilities in ukraine
including the updates published on 19
august by the iaea
we hope that the proposed visit by a
team from the agency
to the zaparizia nuclear power plant and
its surrounding areas will be agreed to
by the two sides as indicated in their
recent statements
we continue to reiterate that the global
order be anchored on international law
the u.n charter and respect for the
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
states thank you
i thank the representative of india for
her statement now i would like to give
the floor to the representative of the
united kingdom
[Music]
thank you mr president
and thank you to under secretary general
dicarlo
for this briefing
the united kingdom remains gravely
concerned about the implications for
nuclear safety security and safeguards
of russia's illegal invasion of ukraine
russia's invasion has disrupted the
operation of nuclear facilities across
ukraine
posed a grave threat to operational
safety
and prevented ukrainian authorities from
carrying out routine safeguarding tasks
instead of calling yet another meeting
on the crisis as apparition russia could
resolve it immediately by withdrawing
its forces from the plant
and all of ukraine and ceasing its
senseless aggression
as well as causing untold suffering to
the ukrainian people
the simple fact is that russia's
invasion
and its efforts to seize by force
ukraine's nuclear plants
has jeopardized the safety of millions
in the region
who would who would be affected by a
nuclear incident in ukraine
meanwhile important nuclear safety and
safeguards activities at the site are
needed more than ever
we welcome progress towards an iaea
technical visit
any visit should take place in a manner
that respects ukraine's sovereignty over
its territory
the secretary general has been clear
that the un can facilitate a visit from
the ukrainian side
and we welcome his and the un's
engagement
we also welcome the efforts of the
ukrainian administration and of iaea
staff
to plan and support a mission
and we call upon russia to provide
appropriate security guarantees
we commend the heroic efforts of
ukrainian staff operating the zaparisian
nuclear power plant despite the great
pressure they are under
they must be allowed to carry out their
duties without threats or further
disruption
cutting off a major supply of
electricity
to the people of ukraine
would further cause immense suffering
as usg de carlo said today
the electricity at the zaparisian
nuclear power plant belongs to ukraine
russia's war
is reckless and irresponsible
a nuclear disaster should
be unthinkable
no member of the united nations
let alone a permanent member of this
council
should bring about that threat by
seeking to take another country's
nuclear facilities by
force russia's actions are contrary to
the principles of the convention of
nuclear safety
and other
international nuclear safety conventions
so we call once more
upon russia
to return full control of all ukraine's
nuclear facilities to their rightful
sovereign owner
to ensure their safe and secure
operation
thank you
i thank the representative of the uk for
his statement now i give the floor to
the representative of mexico
thank you very much mr president
mr president we would like to thank the
under secretary general
dicarlo
for her presentation on the critical
situation
in the subregia
as was pointed out by the secretary
general
avoiding any action that endangers the
integrity and security of the nuclear
power plant
the largest in europe
is a matter of common sense
but to common sense is very often
the least common of all senses
nuclear weapons the npt
that the world has managed to avoid the
use of nuclear weapons
simply out of luck
but luck is not a strategy
to the secretary general
the attacks against the plan
catastrophic humanitarian consequences
in the short medium and long term
for the civilian population
including
far beyond ukraine and far beyond its
neighbors
we also agree with the secretary general
that uh damaging the nuclear plan
is the equivalent
of a collective suicide
i would like to highlight three points
uno
first of all
all of the attacks against the planet
and its environs
must cease immediately
any attack
including the geneva conventions of 1949
and
its additional
under any circumstances to carry out
military operations
it's a matter of priority to respect to
the civilian status of the plant
and to reiterate to withdraw immediately
all military and equipment and personnel
the ukrainian regulatory authority
must have the freedom of access and
effective control over the operation of
the plan
so that
we can respect these seven crucial
pillars
of
nuclear security
we support the request of the secretary
general to establish
a demilitarized zone which would allow
the iaea
to carry out the necessary inspections
in order to have
objective
truthful
and impartial information
on the conditions which exist in the
plant
today
once
and security capabilities to support
as long as ukraine and russia reach an
agreement
resulting
appeal to
put an end to the war in ukraine and to
resume the path to dialogue the conflict
of the recent months and has had an
enormous cost for the civilian
population
irreversible consequences
and so we cannot wait any longer
to establish a ceasefire
when there is political will
and when reason prevails
thank you very much
okay
i thank the representative of mexico for
his statement now i give the floor to a
representative of france
i thank you very much mr president and i
of mrs de carlo for presentation mr
president
as
we've said since the beginning of the
war france is deeply concerned by the
threat
presented by the russian attack in
ukraine over the safety and security of
ukrainian nuclear facilities
asia plant in ukrainian territory was
forcibly seized
by russia
the presence of the actions of the
russian armed forces
in the vicinity it greatly increased the
risk of an accident
and russia bears a responsibility for
the situation
france would like to insist on three uh
simple messages first of all
russia must return to ukraine total
control of the zamboasia nuclear power
plant as well as all of the nuclear
facilities in ukraine
all of the russian military equipment
and personnel must be withdrawn
immediately from the power plant
at the ukrainian uh
the staff which is operating the power
plant must be able to continue its
mission without threat or pressure
secondly france welcomes and supports
the efforts
made by the director general of the iaea
the seven pillars of nuclear safety and
security as defined by the director of
the iaea must be respected
the ability of the iaea to monitor
peaceful nuclear activities in all of
ukraine to ensure the respect of
safeguards uh a capacity which has been
undermined by the actions of russia this
must also be restored
it's important to facilitate as quickly
as possible an expert mission of the
iaea to this upper asia plant this
mission must take place in full respect
of the sovereignty of ukraine over its
territory and over all of its
infrastructure
my friend so welcomes the role of the
united nations in this regard as well as
its readiness to ensure the necessary
logistical support for the deployment of
such a mission from kiev
it also welcomes the agreement and
principle given by ukraine and russia to
the holding of this mission confirmed at
the highest level
and now we need sufficient security
guarantees as well as a commitment from
all the parties so that the mission can
take place in the coming days
france will continue to support at the
highest level the efforts of the iaea to
this end
as was done by the president of the
french republic with president poutine
on the 19th of august
and as she also did with the president
zalensky on the 16th of august and as
was done this morning by the minister
for europe and foreign affairs
during a phone conversation that she had
with sergey lavrov thank you very much
i thank the representative for france
for her statement now i give the floor
to the representative of kenya
thank you mr president i thank usg
rosemary de carlo for her briefing on
the situation concerning the zapariza
nuclear power plant
it is unfortunate that we are having
this discussion for the second time in
just over a week
at the tail end of the tenth review
conference of the parties to the treaty
on the non-proliferation of nuclear
weapons
the objective of this treaty is to
prevent the spread of nuclear weapons
and weapons technology promote
cooperation in the peaceful uses of
nuclear energy
and further the goal of achieving
nuclear disarmament and general and
complete disarmament
mr president the deployment of these
weapons can have a long-term apocalyptic
effect on humanity biodiversity and the
environment
indeed a stray or deliberate targeting
of any nuclear installation even those
intended for peaceful purposes will turn
them into nuclear weapons with equally
devastating capabilities
we therefore remain deeply concerned
that shelling shelling continues around
the environment of the zaparizia nuclear
power plant which is exposing thousands
of civilians to grave security risks as
well as power cut-offs
in this regard kenya welcomes the recent
visit to lev by the secretary general
and fully support his plea for the
withdrawal of military equipment and
personnel as well as an immediate and to
all military activity around what is in
fact europe's largest
nuclear power plant to guarantee its
safety
we also urge the immediate and
unconditional access to the site for
experts and officials from the iaea to
conduct the critically needed safety
security and safeguards verification
activities
we welcome the expression of corporation
by the parties in this regard
mr president
kenya continues to call for restraint
from any actions that may further
escalate the situation
we continue to reiterate as we have
stated time and time again the need to
shift gears to an immediate cessation of
hostilities and the deployment of
available diplomatic tools to end the
conflict
such a cessation should set the
foundation for the negotiation of a
lasting peace settlement that guarantees
the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of ukraine which kenya
continues to reaffirm i thank you
i thank the representative of kenya for
her statement i'll give the floor to the
representative of brazil
thank you mr president
i thank usg rosemary de carlo for her
briefing
two weeks ago we met in this very
chamber to discuss this very topic
we all expressed our concerns with the
potentially catastrophic and lasting
consequences for human health and the
environment
that substantial damage to this upper
rigid nuclear power plant would entail
we reaffirmed
that any armed attack
on and threat against nuclear facilities
devoted to peaceful purposes constitutes
a violation of the principles of the u.n
charter
international law
and and the institute of the agency as
unanimously recognized by the
international atomic agency energy
agency
general conference
we reiterated the state's
responsibilities to ensure compliance
with applicable instruments on nuclear
safety and security
such as the conventional nuclear safety
the joint convention on the safety of
spent fuel
and the convention on the physical
protection of nuclear material and its
amendment
we agreed
it was high time
the iaea
deployed an expert mission to the znpp
without delay
yet the situation remains unchanged
shelling around the znpp continues
and we meet once again
our inability
to translate words into actions is
pushing us to the brink of reason
two weeks ago
the iaea
assessed that the situation posed
no immediate threat to nuclear safety
but as the situation drags on
the threat
was once limit that was once limited
becomes an increasingly concrete risk
we renew our call to all parties to
refrain from any measure that could
jeopardize the safety and security of
the znpp
as well as its safe operation
brazil recognizes the indispensable role
that the international atomic
energy agency can play in taking the
necessary steps
to help ensure nuclear safety and
security and prevent any radiological
consequences for the population and the
environment in the region and beyond
we therefore welcome news that
that negotiations for deployment of an
a
iaea expert mission to zapolicio
are progressing and we urge the parties
to allow its
immediate dispatch and i thank you
thank you thank you mr president we
thank usg de carlo for her information
colleagues we had a meeting on this
very issue less than two weeks ago
our position has not changed and
although we are fully aware of the
importance of the matter
there is one simple issue that stands on
top of everything
we are here only because of this
senseless unjustified and provoked and
illegal war
everything we have been discussing here
on ukraine during this long six months
comes from the unjustified actions of
russia
from its war of choice
and now also the continued danger of a
nuclear catastrophe
mr president albania condemns the
militarization of nuclear power plant
plant in ukraine
we condemn any action of violence inside
or near the zaparisia nuclear power
plant or against this personnel
ukrainian personnel operating the plant
under the russian invasion must be able
to carry out their important tasks
without restriction
threats or pressure
albania reiterates its full and
continued support for the
iaea and its staff to access immediately
safely and without any impediment all
nuclear facilities in ukraine and they
get engaged directly with the
responsible ukrainian staff at the
facilities
we support the expert mission to the
scene as soon as possible to help
stabilize the nuclear safety safety and
security situation
at the zaparisha npp to conduct safety
security and safeguards protocols
mr president
we remain very worried by the reports
that the very reason of the presence of
the russian military personnel
at the ukrainian nuclear plant is to
disconnect the power plant from the
ukrainian energy network and divert its
energy for russian interest
we welcome the clear position of sg
guterres on the matter and reiterate our
position
the parisia power plant is ukrainian
its electricity is ukrainian
russia and its troop have no place there
no part in it
in conclusion we reiterate our full
solidarity with ukraine and its people
and call again on the russian federation
to put an end to this war and
immediately withdraw all its armed
forces from ukraine including from
ukrainian nuclear facilities if they are
truly interested in preventing incidents
that
incidents with catastrophic consequences
for al for all of us
there is no reason for russian troops to
be in ukraine there is no need for
russian troops to be in a nuclear power
plant thank you
okay
i thank the representative of albania
for her statement i shall now make a
statement in my capacity as a
representative of
china i thank usg tikalo for her
briefing
when the council last considered the
issue of safety of ukraine's nuclear
facilities members expressed concern
about the safety of the zaparosia
nuclear power plant
it is disconcerting that the nuclear
power plant is still
under shelling in recent days while the
shelling has not yet posed an immediate
threat to the safety of the nuclear
power plant as iaea director general
crossy stated this could change at any
moment
there is no room for trial and error
when it comes to the safety and security
of nuclear facilities any single
incident could lead to a serious nuclear
accident
with irreversible consequences for the
ecosystem and public health of ukraine
and the neighboring countries
china once again called on the parties
concerned to exercise maximum restraint
strictly abide by the provisions of
relevant international law earnestly
implement the seven pillars proposed by
director general grossi
avoid actions that might endanger
nuclear safety and security and minimize
the risk of accidents
china has always supported the iaea in
fulfilling its safeguards
responsibilities in strict accordance
with its mandate and playing an active
role in promoting nuclear safety and
security
under the current circumstances it is
necessary for the iaea to conduct a site
visit to the zaporosia nuclear power
plant as soon as possible to make a
professional and technical assessment of
the safety and security situation of the
nuclear facilities we have taken note
that both russia and ukraine have made
positive statements about the visit
we hope that all parties concerned will
clear political obstacles strengthen
communication and co-op collaboration
adhere to the issue-oriented approach
and reach agreement on the timing and
details of the visit as soon as possible
so that the iaea mission can be carried
out in a timely manner
colleagues
the safety and security of nuclear
facilities
based on the common welfare of mankind
to deal with the issue we must adhere to
signs and rationality adhere to the
spirit of
humanity adhere to communication and
cooperation and go beyond political
positions go beyond hostile differences
and go beyond military considerations we
must not allow the tragedies of
chernobyl and fukushima nuclear
accidents to be repeated
to fundamentally eliminate the nuclear
safety risks after the parisian nuclear
power plant the international community
must promote the de-escalation of the
situation in a responsible manner work
on diplomatic efforts and political
solutions guide the parties back to
dialogue and negotiations and achieve a
ceasefire and cessation of hostilities
at an early date china once again calls
upon all parties concerned to pay
attention to each other's legitimate
security concerns build a balanced
effective and sustainable security
architecture
and make unrepeating efforts towards the
proper resolution of the ukraine crisis
and achieving lasting peace and
stability in the region
i resume my function as president of the
council
i've taken note that the representative
of the russian federation has requested
the floor to make additional remarks now
i gave the floor to the russian
federation
thank you mr president
[Music]
gathered here
because
the
compelled us to request this meeting
have not disappeared
the shellings of the npp and energy by
the ukrainian armed forces continue
despite the fact that the npp does not
have
russian heavy artillery nor
is there a fire being conducted from
there we have said this many times and
this
can be confirmed by the um objective
control data
including from satellites
but today
once again we've heard the old record
saying that russia is the guilty party
guilty for everything
the un undergrads the developments
surrounding uh by the um npp is being
distorted and obvious facts are being
passed over in silent or denied and all
of this is done
with
one goal in mind to make sure that the
kiev
proteges are whitewashed regardless what
it is that they do they get carte
blanche
for any
reckless
activities knowing that they will be
whitewashed by their patrons
once again we are called upon to agree
to the ia visit something which agreed
in june already and reconfirmed that
many times including
today some western colleagues are of the
view that there's only one and the most
simple way out of the situation namely
withdraw russian forces from there and
create a demilitarized area surrounding
these projects
this is an irresponsible statement
it does not take into account
at all the need to have conditions for
the safe functioning of the zappos mpp
once again we appeal to you to stop
covering up what your key of protesters
are doing and compel them to
stop stop them attacking the
zaparoji npp which can which is fraught
with the risk of accident and radiate
radioactive contamination of european
countries i thank you
okay
thank the representative of the russian
federation
i should not give a floor to the
representative of ukraine
well thank you mr president
distinguished members of security
council
i would like to thank under secretary
general dicarlo
for her informative briefing
i wish we had been
gathered here
by russia
to hear the only thing that the entire
world
wants to hear
and that is a statement
that russia demilitarizes
the parisian npp
withdraws his troops
and hands this over
to the government of ukraine
instead we wasted more than one hour
to listen
to a slew of fictitious
sound bites
the terrorist state does not stop
playing around with the international
community
once again it has the audacity to
convene a u.n security council meeting
to discuss its own provocations
it's owen tara
at the znpp
let me reiterate the current situation
makes it clear that all that will
ultimately remove
the nuclear threats stemming from the
illegal russian presence at the nuclear
power plant is
the withdrawal of the russian weapons
and troops
and the return of the station to the
legitimate control by ukraine
ukraine greatly appreciates the efforts
of the iaea
and the u.n to ensure the safety and
security
of the of
all ukrainian nuclear facilities
against the backdrop of the russian
invasion
we have always underlined the importance
of the full and consistent
implementation
by the agency of its mandate
in this regard
since the beginning of russia's
occupation
of zad npp
ukraine has insisted
on the need to send a mission
to decide and has negotiated its
modalities with the iaea
we welcome the readiness of the iaea
director general to send the
mission
to the occupied zed znpp
and the visit should be conducted in
street compliance with the national
legislation of ukraine and with full
respect of its international obligations
earlier today ukraine's foreign minister
coleba
has responded to the director general
sleta dated august 17th
regarding the above mission
as follows from the letter the iaea
proposal for the itinerary is in
compliance with the national legislation
of ukraine and in general might be
accepted
further arrangements are to be made
based on the security conditions and
require communication of detailed route
plans and other logistical aspects as
soon as possible
we continue to believe
that the mission's effectiveness can be
bolstered by incorporating military and
political components
baked by u.n expertise
considering the scale of the current
challenges and threats we also urge the
iaea
to consider a permanent presence of its
experts at the zedd npp
until the competent ukrainian
authorities regain full control
over this nuclear facility
russian demonstration of the wish to
organize the mission
to the zad npp has only one purpose
let's proceed from the basics
znpp
is a ukrainian facility located on
ukrainian territory
the occupiers have trained some of the
hostages
in what they should say and what they
shouldn't show to the iaea
that is why it is really important to
conduct the mission
in a way that would allow the
international community
to see the real situation and not a
russian theatrical show
it is imperative that the mission takes
place a
at the request of ukraine b
at the ukrainian nuclear facility c
is covered by the agreement on the
application of safeguards between
ukraine and the iaea
russia's role is to ensure the physical
security of the mission
russia is turning the issue of nuclear
safety
at the facility into a farce
a circus
it downplays the significance of the
threats
it has created
and diverts attention
from the urgent issue of
demilitarization and the occupation of
the station
the entire international community has
been demanding these for almost six
months
this is what the iaea says
russia pretends not to hear this and
continues to invent newer and newer ways
of using the peaceful station for
military purposes
it is obvious that any mission beat the
iaea
or the un
while at the station
will record
flagrant violations of norms and
requirements for nuclear safety
therefore russia is trying to avoid
responsibility
but it will not succeed
russia needs the znpp as a means of
waging war
but there is another aspect
russia is trying at any cost to cover
the needs of the temporarily occupied
crimea and other tot
perhaps zaparisia hersone regions
in electricity because the publicized
illegal
electric bridge has never covered these
needs and will not cover them
moreover
russia needs the znpp for propaganda
purposes
because the the occupation of the plant
will mean a failure of putin's campaign
in the south of ukraine
now about shelling
russian narratives about ukrainian
shelling of the station do not stand up
to scrutiny
nobody who is at least conscious
can imagine that ukraine would target a
nuclear power plant
at tremendous risk of nuclear
catastrophe
and on its own territory
such a catastrophe would lead to
numerous deaths and pollution for many
years to come
we have already lost thousands of human
lives and thousands of square kilometers
of our territory
of the exclusion zone around chernobyl
after 1986.
we are mourning thousands of lives of
ukrainians killed by russians
in their war against ukraine
we suffer from genocide conducted by
russians on the occupied territories
there they kidnap thousands of children
left orphaned after their parents are
killed by the russian army
we will never forget it and we will do
everything to save each ukrainian life
what we can do here in the un format is
to name things as they are
russians forget that we live in a
century of modern technologies
and there as their crimes in butcher and
mariupol were clearly seen from
satellite
the shelling under the false flag will
be clearly filmed again
dear colleagues
turning back to the international
mission to to the znpp
let me stress that the need to send such
a mission to the zedd npp is primarily
due to violations of all seven pillars
of nuclear
and nuclear security that arose as a
result of the illegal presence there of
the russian army and ross atom
the constant presence of the iaea
and other experts
at this station could become a
determining factor in the context of
these demilitarization and the
occupation
the international community in eastern
must continue to apply political
pressure on the aggressive state of
russia and demand full demilitarization
and
the occupation
let me stress that nuclear security and
safety
is an absolute priority for everyone in
the world and russia must immediately
and without any conditions withdrawal is
troops
stop all provocations all shelling
it is unacceptable that russia is
deliberately putting all of us
on the brink of a global nuclear
disaster
as soon as russia withdraws
the troops from the facility on which
they simply have no right to be
the threat of a nuclear disaster will
disappear
just a similar threat disappeared as
soon as russian troops withdrew from the
chernobyl nuclear power plant
and the exclusion zone
and this threat will no longer exist
just as it does not exist
at three other ukrainian nuclear power
plants
kuminiski npp
rivne npp
and south ukraine npp
i thank you
i thank the representative of ukraine
for his statement
if there are no council members
inscribed on the list of my speaker
i announced it meetings are turned